tell me what's on the post-it why do we
get off track what's on the post no the
on the post it said i think you'll like
it as a fellow comedian it says porn is
happening in the past
when when i thought that i was like we
know things they don't know
like current events
like it was a different president when
that gangbang happened
like if you were being if you were
truthfully putting together a historical
collage of the year 67 you have to throw
in all the porn that was happening
that's true because they because in
between takes they were still going i
think they're going to desegregate those
schools oh can we get the fluffer over
here here we go okay you know
so that was still going on in between
all the uh that's fantastic
by the way porn is happening in the past
that sounds like a slogan for a product
or like like nike porn is happening in
the past and then john lennon's you know
insta karma starts playing and and then
it's like an ultra glide commercial or
something i don't know but or like a cam
website they're like
be with us right now okay can't you live
in the net can't you come in the now